well that does it for us as we leave you
let's take a look back and all that
matter this week we all here help you'll
have a great weekend big norm to let
people in some of the hardest hit areas
are still waiting on food it's the most
difficult job because it's in the middle
of the ocean we can have immediate aid
so that we don't collapse into a
humanitarian crisis North Korean
government has threatened to shoot down
American planes felt like your reaction
devastating for North Korea the
president's words only reignited the
protests love to see one of these NFL
owners to say get that son of a [ __ ]
off the field right now he's fired
Border Patrol was getting ready to talk
to the media
a man from Chiapas jumped the fence has
been a constant evolution we were
arresting over half a million people
illegal entrants a year are you Rick
Pitino hasn't been charged with any
crimes what is the reaction among the
players they're sad
Arabian women have been fighting for the
right to drive I think this is a victory
for us another step you have no idea how
great this feels to be back here at work
in the people's house
rebuilding Humpty Dumpty there was a lot
of damage inside that that had to get
fixed they put you back together it'll
be back together is there a sport you
wanted more in I won't rugby in
basketball pretty equally especially
because uh I've been getting a lot of
chatter from Great Britain Great
Britain's trash talk
oh oh of course that's what they do
Harlan Coben joins us back at the table
good to see you again know that your
best-selling artha when your name is so
much bigger than the title of the book
the chip with you and all because in the
book it sounds very contentious it
sounds very low it's intense it's like a
marriage it has summers and winters it
is best not talked about you leave it
along as you've walk out into the middle
here it starts to sway if you carrying
on your back what you say about that
experts believe Leonardo da Vinci drew
nude Mona Lisa take that in for a second
less walter isaacson about the house yes
he would know what is the book a woman's
I can't tell maybe my eyesight's not
something no that's a woman you can tell
by looking at the breast area okay those
are not man boobs Playboy founder who
led his business empire in his pajamas
died of natural causes he was 91 you
have taken great pride in celebration of
pleasure yes well I don't see a lot to
be said for the celebration of pain
celebration of pleasure Charles ii 91 he
said his motto was I'm the boy who
dreamed the dream a lot of other boys my
Playboy magazine
[Music]
you